buenas noches en su primer mensaje a los
peruanos francisco sagasti ha prometido
elecciones limpias y transparentes para
las elecciones presidenciales y
congresales de abril de 2021 otro
aspecto importante de su alocución ha
sido que va a redoblar o mejor dicho
mejorar la atención en la pandemia del
coi 19 las autoridades peruanas esperan
una segunda ola de contagios
seguidamente ha anunciado que va a
redoblar la seguridad ciudadana en ese
sentido ha dicho que va a exigir a la
fiscalía que investigue y trate de
ubicar junto con la policía a los
jóvenes desaparecidos durante las
jornadas de protesta el presidente ha
sido enfático que no habrá impunidad
contra los que resulten responsables por
la muerte de los dos jóvenes en estas
jornadas de las últimas horas en la
diferencia que hay entre el estilo entre
manuel merino y francisco sagasti es que
merino cuando juramentó en su corto
gobierno él se reunió con un sector
conservador del país en cambio francisco
sagasti tiene un estilo
más de diálogo de tender puentes con la
población sobre todo con los jóvenes es
en ese sentido que ha ofrecido que las
puertas del palacio de gobierno estarán
abiertas para todo aquel que quiera
proponer una propuesta que mejore el
gobierno o una queja para mejorar la
atención a la población
francisco ahora le pregunto en qué
estado se encuentran las acusaciones
contra vizcarra
la fiscalía peruana así avanzando en el
proceso por lo pronto ha conseguido que
una corte ordene el impedimento de
salida del país por 18 meses para el
exmandatario esto ha puesto en digamos
en zozobra o mejor dicho en preocupación
a la defensa del exmandatario porque es
temen que esto sea el preludio de un
pedido de prisión preventiva por eso es
que están atentos al desenvolvimiento
del tribunal constitucional y si es que
obtienen un fallo favorable pueden
usarlo para una medida legal en estos
momentos el presidente francisco sagasti
está saliendo del palacio legislativo y
recibe los honores a su alta investidura
por las fuerzas militares del perú
francisco gracias por la información que
tenga usted una muy buena noche
francisco zacarías corresponsal de
france 24 en lima